I am your new I I ran out of ideas so
today I'm so from now on I am going to
so from now on I am going to report the
news reporting I'm doing the news now
I hate drama but I need to do this this
is my purpose this is my real purpose
and I think this might be my core
message I made that video I did do I
still stand by I do hate drama
but I need to do this drama show now
because team is quitting and stairs is
scarce let's I need a I need my I need
to be original here otherwise this is
not gonna work
let's get slamming on the Beauty pubes
we'll get into the noobs let's go inside
let's go inside the stories I like that
one actually let's do that one let's go
inside the stories the scoop oh no
that's been scoop is better let's get
into the latest scoops
our first story you will not believe
stairs has come out as homosexual
also his parents confirms that they
think he's gay now
we reached out to scares or a comment
about the situation and I'm gay
I told my parents I'm gay alright and my
mom is super homophobic um both like my
mom and my dad actually like grab my
balls and they both sincerely think I'm
gay now oh my god I just I can't [ __ ]
believe it and I'll see other piece I'm
gay syndicate has confirmed that he is
the vice president of csgo
lotto as you can see here on the title
and thumbnail oh my god I need to create
a website as well another breaking story
this is the big one guys idubbbz has
also come out as gay in his coming out
video I'm gay
now I don't personally give my opinion
on the show no matter what but I
personally think this is terrific
everyone support idubbbz
in this decision he made the next news
might shock you it involves a dear
friend of mine and you know it pains me
to do this but jacksepticeye says I got
to see all my friends jacksepticeye
doesn't have any friends why is he lying
about this we don't know why did Jack
lie about the situation we don't know
coming up next
noobs new the next scoop is might shock
you a scientific breakthrough has been
done in the YouTube community today as
Roman Atwood discovers water colder than
zero degrees
now we didn't know there was possible
for water to be colder than zero degrees
but it seems that Roman Atwood has done
it he also attempted to swim in this
what coldest water ever and it seems
that he survived somehow good Roman
Atwood be a superhuman we reached out to
Roman Eduard for a response Roman Atwood
is that we're having a little Roman
Atwood live here on skype yeah dude I'd
just weigh in it I found the coldest
water ever and I just went straight in I
needed to prove you dude that it was
sick dog thank you for your continuing
support in the YouTube community Roman
Atwood has murdered his own children
we reached out to Roman Atwood for a
response yeah dude it's just it's just a
clickbait title so you're saying that
you didn't murder your children Yemen I
wouldn't I wouldn't I wouldn't do that
dude why did you put it in the title
Roman wrote Roman Roman has yet to leave
a response the next scoop everyone leafy
decides to leave you two he is
officially done with YouTube and I for
one support leave there has been a lot
of scoops today but there are many more
scoops to cover wait what's this what's
this news team
what's this comedyshortsgamer has found
the best game ever twice
good comedy gates short gamers
potentially suffer from amnesia we reach
out to comedyshortsgamer for a response
this just in
right now live on the scoops PewDiePie's
dad is gay we reach out to purify his
dad for a response
[Music]
absolutely news breaking hey guys next
up it looked like faze rain murdered his
roommate it's pretty big news here I
don't know if it's true or not but it
seems here there's a knife and going
into his roommates back I'm not gonna
dig any deeper than this because it
don't [ __ ] matter for sure but it
seems yes face rain did murder his
roommate that was it for this week's
excuse hope you're all a fan of this new
show format that I will do for a year
and then quit team just come back I
can't do this [ __ ] job alright I
don't I can't can't do it I can't do it
favorite and like this video for more
scoops PewDiePie now over a lot of
subscribers
[Music]
Oh
gotta get to school boy
[Music]
you